all right
all right Sam
Sam uh where's your girl where are you
from originally I am from hotlanta
Georgia is that right
tell me about your family oh I am the
bottom of five kids and my daddy died
when I was nine months old and I was
raised by a bunch of strong southern
women most of them black
uh I am a product
of being raised by five or six very
strong southern women and I'm proud to
say that so you're adopted
my father died and my mother had to go
back to school and uh oh so you had like
so I was raised by a series of uh we
called them Maids got it
how far are you in school
five years of college I did not get my I
got a ba in journalism in 82 then I went
to grad school but I did not write my
Master's thesis so I'm five five years
of Journalism school what did you want
to do in terms of what did you do with
work
your career well what happened so well I
was a journalist for seven years after
college I did it for seven years I was
working most I was living in Santa Cruz
California writing for the the left-wing
very left-wing radical rag called the
Santa Cruz Express and
freelance and mostly environmental
journalism and then
because the universe has a sense of
humor at age 30 I went from being a
radical left-wing social justice Warrior
environmental muckraker to being a real
estate agent for Century 21 Real Estate
uh I made a horrendous wrong turn in my
life at age 30 but it sure was nice the
money was nice and so I was off and on
again a real estate agent and a house
flipper is where I made my most money
between
1987 and 2008 and I red pilled in 2008
and went down the this rabbit Hall down
into what we call the doomsphere yeah so
you you describe yourself as a Doomer I
do describe myself as a doom so what is
a Doomer
okay I think
I think so if you brought 30 people in
here Mark who just who described
themselves as a Doomer you would get 30
different answers like Doomsday
theorists it
well there there are so many rabbit
holes I want to spend just briefly
telling you who is not a Doomer just so
I don't know where you I have an idea
where you fall into this group
so you have on one end what we call the
clueless [ __ ] morons that's the
absolute clueless morons
uh I'm talking the Donald Trump level of
Clueless [ __ ] more you know the the
basket of deplorables over here usually
on the right but not always then the
vast majority of the bell curves is what
we call normies what doomers call
normies and this is
you know 99 of the population
normies and they
they range from being clueless morons
but not clueless [ __ ] but just plain
old clueless morons they just paid no
attention to this and as you move
generally towards the the left I guess
going this way from your camera as you
move towards the left you go from
Clueless [ __ ] to what we call the
apocal optimist
uh an apocal optimistic definition of an
apocal Optimus is somebody who basically
knows we're [ __ ] but thinks things are
going to turn out okay anyway
uh so you're moving so most people go
through the phases
clueless [ __ ] to apocal Optimus so
doomers is the next step to the left and
where the faults who realize how [ __ ]
we are and we know we're not coming we
don't think we're not coming out of it
we know we're not coming out of it but
then you get down here
and there's a million different uh
rabbit holes that and so I am pretty I'm
probably the second most radical level
of doomor there might be one
one step away so but I'm but I'm
I have a lot of people in the
doomisphere who hate me because I'm too
radical for them a pessimist throughout
your life
I don't use the word pessimist I use the
word I'm a realist you're a realist I'm
a realist
it has nothing to do with optimism or
pessimism at this point it's I I am a
realist I have spent
the past 14 years of my life what I've
dedicated my life to is is uh
study and how [ __ ] we are and
the more and more you figure out how
[ __ ] we are you fig there's no way out
of this it ain't happening we are not
coming out of this it's we're [ __ ] on
every level every level mankind doesn't
have a
you know mankind has a history of of
doing things to
save itself or or find a new technology
or a new something that might I figured
you were an apocal optimist
you probably figured right it's
technology that got us into this dude
technology is not getting us out it's
getting us deeper into it uh
uh and and and
I again you know there's so many
definitions of a Doomer now there's so
what I
I call it the Doomsday Prophecy pool
okay we got the shallow end and the deep
end the shallow end of the Doomsday
Prophecy pulls what's going on outside
your door for people who don't realize
this we're on Skid Row in uh in La if
you want to see these shallow end
of the Doomsday Prophecy pool I'm
talking about the the the social
disintegration the economic
disintegration you know the purely
human-centered
uh just collapse of of what's going on
all across the board and then you get
into the deep end which is where I swim
which is the ecological collapse going
on which you know and when it goes uh
it's going to suck down the shallow end
so that's where I swim around in mostly
I mean I'm certainly in the shallow end
too
and but you're probably more of a Doomer
than I am about what's going on outside
your door but I'm down into the
ecological
uh
tell me tell me what you see coming for
our future
it's right here on the shirt
sorry we're [ __ ]
and uh it it it's on every level there
is no good news coming out anymore there
is no good news it is a permanent state
of Crisis this planet is in and it the
news is bad and it's getting worse uh
every single day and
the sooner this I I am a
absolute defender of the collapse of
global industrial civilization and the
extinction of the human race I am I am
cheering on the collapse of everything
uh well not the not the planet we I'm
cheering on the collapse of the human
race and the extinction of our species
to save this planet will do fine without
us the planet would be a hell of a lot
better without us I believe that it's
clear
and so people ask me to like like
what's the problem and so I want to tell
you what's not the problem
climate change is not the problem
climate change is a problem it's a big
problem but it's not the problem
uh fossil fuels
are a problem they are not the problem
capitalism is a big ass problem it is
not the problem people who know me will
be shocked to say
overpopulation
too many people on this planet
is not the problem too many humans on
the planet is the a huge problem
the problem when you've spent as much
time as I have down here the problem is
in one word the problem is humans
the problem is humans uh you know they
all joke about the space aliens coming
down here the space Island were to come
down it would take him five minutes
to identify the problem on this planet
the problem is humans
every every single problem on the planet
is a direct result of humans
and once you understand this
that what the real problem is I call it
peeling back the layers of the onion
you know you got the clueless [ __ ]
morons and you got the clueless morons
and you get down to the apocal Optimus
and then you get you you have to get a
whole new onion out but once you peel
back enough and you understand what the
problem is
is humans
what do you mean like human greed or
just humans it's it's the original it's
our original sin where we're we're born
humans we cannot
stop what we're doing to this phone
can't do it it's beyond
it is be and I'm not talking the
technological challenge at this point
it's the it's
we're not up to to The Challenge on any
level from technological to biological
to spiritual we are not uh we are a
grand failed experiment
and uh okay
put it that's right let's say your house
is infested
with rats
you call the Exterminator the
Exterminator goes what's your problem
you do not say to the Exterminator my
problem is I got a bunch of rat [ __ ]
piled enough I need you to come clean up
the rats yet you don't tell the
exterminant you know I got rats raiding
my food supply you need to come figure
out a way to rescue my food supply you
don't tell the Exterminator I'm afraid
that rats are going to give me some
disease your answer to the Exterminator
is rats
when he asked you what your problem is
it's one word it's the one word and
rats humans the problem going on in our
house is we have what uh ecologist
William Reese
what does William Reese call us he's we
are the at the Peril parasitic plague
phase
that's what we are we are we are
parasites
we are literally cancer eating our host
uh we're we're the viral every one of
those words where every one of them and
as long as as long as one human is
walking this planet
uh
the the planet's [ __ ] and in every
single day that this [ __ ] goes on
because we're we're out of here it's not
a matter of if it's a matter of when but
every single day that we go on for
another day it's going to take this
planet that much longer to recover it's
that many more of our fellow earthlings
that were taken down with us and and
this is the tragedy
out of this whole thing is
is all of the you know these 10 million
species that we share this planet with
brother
that that did nothing nothing to deserve
this nothing to deserve this
and I I'm so so we owe it to them but
when you when you
truly get to this point and I'm only say
many doomers are down to this point when
when you've truly face the the the
absolute horror of what is going on in
this planet
and realize you you have to
learn to live with it for the rest of
your life you understand that humans
need to go and so there there's two ways
to make humans go is increase the death
rate or decrease the birth rate and I do
not know one single fellow Doomer I have
never advocated increasing the death
rate I absolutely love people I am a
people person I consider myself to you
know to be sociable and I enjoy the
company I I would I was just telling my
friend if
I would it would be party central at
Sam's house every day I I absolutely
you're not one of these reclusive
Hermits that no I absolutely love people
uh I hate being alone and I I'm uh
involuntary hermit I guess you could say
uh so it's not people
it's humans
so what we need to do is re is reduce
the birth rate down to zero not down you
know the Georgia they now defunct
Georgia guidestone said 500 million
people that's a good start getting a you
know we need to get down to zero
through
through reducing the birth rate down to
zero but it's never going to happen
see I got a vasectomy at age 22 so I've
greatest decision I ever made at age 22
before I had any children
I got what's I have the golden snip
award there's this group called the
voluntary human extinction movement
in the golden snip
there's not many of us in the club
rather
sterilization before the first child I
am at that and that was at age 20 and it
was hard to get an epistectomy at age 22
without having any kids but I did it
best decision I ever made in my life
hands down I I I'm thinking my God if I
had kids and grandchildren right now
I would be
I
I wouldn't be suicidal I would be
homicidal I would want to be increasing
the death rate you know what I'm saying
if I had children and grandchildren I
thank God have we always been on this
path like in the 1800s 1900s where we
in the same boat that we're in right now
you mean Humanity yeah
read Don Quixote 1500.
Cervantes in 1500 when the population of
this planet probably was 500 million or
less
250 years before the Industrial
Revolution
uh he was trying to warn us the path
that we were on and of course if he if
you've read Don Quixote I mean if you
haven't read dog yet you need to change
that but in 1500 Miguel Cervantes was a
Doomer
and trying to warn people and but he was
considered an absolute
raving lunatic just like a lot of people
listening to this they're going to think
where the hell did Mark find this guy uh
obviously out on Skid Row uh that that
he's got one of these blithering crazy
people uh you live uh in Texas
I'm in Ithaca New York right now that's
where I met but
the way I explain this and again I don't
know when I say this people like they
think I'm joking what's what's going on
on this planet make no mistake about
this what's going on on this planet
right now while we're having this
conversation
is the biggest story in human history
going back way back behind 300 000 years
I mean this story what's going on right
now outside I mean I'm not just talking
Skid Row I'm talking on this anywhere on
this planet today brother you take the
invention of Fire
you take every single War we have ever
fought
from day one combine them you take the
invention of agriculture you take the
Industrial Revolution you take the
invention of fossil fuels you add it all
up together
it does not
does not even rate what is going on in
front of our eyes
we are killing a planet and as far as I
can tell Mark 99 of the people either
they're not aware of this or you or you
make them aware of it and they just
don't want to hear it
that they they have no interest in these
single biggest event in the history of
our this is the biggest event since that
meteor comment
s what 66 mil this is the biggest story
in 66 million years and as far as I can
tell Dude a few people are talking about
climate change how do you think our
demise will begin
begin
we wanted to take the camera and just
stick it out the door
take a look outside the window
look outside your you don't even have to
live on Skid Row this scene
and I'm going I'm gonna I'm gonna paddle
out of the deep end back into the
shallow man what you see going on on
Seventh we're on Seventh Street in Los
Angeles California
I was just remarking to my friend I'm
saying this looks like Austin Texas
uh it looks like I'm back home in Austin
uh this is not going to be Skid Row in
in in five years it goes on every every
city it's a well it is coming to a
neighborhood near you this is going this
is going to be the norm
uh the
what you're seeing here this is the
little cracks
uh
uh that if you've ever seen that movie
Blue Velvet
with a Dennis Hopper uh
the opening all you got to do is go on
YouTube and put in the opening scene to
Blue Velvet oh God it was David Lemon
David Lynch directed out for the guys
out he's out there watering his grass
and he's got his little green lawn and
his flight ticket fence and his rose
bushes and he's out there watering his
grass and he has a heart attack
and he falls down on his little
manicured lawn with the white ticket
sets and then the camera goes this deep
under the surface and all of those worms
and and things just chewing and eating I
mean and that movie was 40 years ago
that uh David Lynch was saying we're
this far
where this far from your little Suburban
Lawn and your white picket fence and uh
this right here is is what it's going to
look like
to most of us
now you go over there to Somalia they
would they would trade places with these
guys
in a heartbeat they would they would
love to be uh having all the luxuries
these guys on Skid Row are having is
there any way that mankind can avoid
this feat there's no way
no way
it's uh there's gonna be a a few little
minor
successes here and there so you know all
of these debates what uh collapse is
going to look like and uh if I don't can
I plug my YouTube channel sure so I have
a my YouTube channel is called collapse
Chronicles that's what what I do with my
life is I Chronicle the collapse of this
planet that's what I've dedicated my
life to just like you've dedicated doing
what you're doing I dedicate my life
literally to chronicling the collapse of
the planet
I would say there's two major schools of
thought
there's like the stair step where it's
going to do we're going to fall and then
we're going to come back and then you
know it's going to look like Lurch along
like this for a couple of hundred years
and then there's the Seneca Cliff this
is the Hugo Barney
uh he's a famous collapsatologist it's
called The Seneca it's the Seneca Cliff
that we're basically going to be going
along in a fairly even Keel and then
overnight we're going to go from here to
here instead of a and I I honestly don't
know
he he now that I I love the debate it as
long as people are having or as long as
people are having the debate uh that's
the important thing it's it's it's not
that important to me it's it's one of
the big questions I get all the time is
when is this going to happen is this
when light and what I finally learned to
say is March 17th
2074 at 5 14 PM is when it's going to
happen you know it doesn't matter I
don't understand
why people
are so concerned I guess what they're
trying to do am I going to be dead
before this bites me and my guilty ass
now I'm 63 years old
uh when I when I read pilled back in
2008
I was I was generally thinking
2070 which was very convenient to me
because I would be 100 I'm going to be
111 years old and you're 27. very
convenient to me that figured 2070
I'm probably moving closer to 2050 when
I'll be conveniently 91 years old but
whenever it happens
I'm still
if I have any hope in my life is that
I'm going to get out of here
with the screen door just hitting me on
my guilty ass on my way out but uh if if
you're under good Lord under the age of
50
you're [ __ ] and and and and and more
and more people are understanding
could you imagine being 23 years old
instead of 63 years old and coming into
this knowledge
that there's no way out
and
so it all comes down to
how are you going to live the rest of
your life they're the only decision you
need to make from this I don't care if
you're 23 or 60. they every one of us
need to need to examine Our Lives
and say is this what I want to be doing
when this [ __ ] show comes down because
it could come it could the the Santa
Claus Cliff version could be very much
correct and it could be here quicker
than I think I guarantee you my late
great friend Gail zawacki uh when I was
interviewing her for my show uh
her answer was I don't know when this is
coming but I don't want to be here when
it and neither do you well she died last
year we so Gail got out with the screen
door just hitting her on her guilty ass
on the way out so it'll be disease it'll
be famine it'll be it all it's it it
it's it's going to be all of the above
uh now but of course the big question is
are a few people gonna make it through
the bottleneck so here's a term
just doesn't really have I this is a
better bottle
okay you might hear the term
bottleneck
so here this this is this is one version
I'm saying this is the 8 billion right
we're right here at 8 billion at this
ring population yeah population and
where what we're doing is heading into
the
heading into this bottleneck
and the question is how many people are
coming out of the top
uh some people say 2 billion
some people say zero so some may survive
yeah so that's the big but but
Global industrial civilization is gone
you know if a few people
actually if a huge if a few humans do
survive this it's it's not going to be
you know what I'm saying it's it's not
going to be this and I mean I I again I
don't know I am hoping that zero of us
are going to survive it I mean I I want
this to be an extinction level event
what whatever form it takes again the
sooner the better
uh as much as is is
much as I am not saying I want to
increase the death rate
but if if Mother Earth is saying I'm
sick and tired of this [ __ ]
uh and and just get rid of it there's
this myth out there about how
Mother Earth is just going to shake us
off
like a bunch of fleas have you ever
tried to shake a flea off dude you can't
shake those [ __ ] off and you're gonna
hit those virus I get in the God damn it
he's still there where where did where
did this [ __ ] [ __ ] that Mother
Earth is just gonna shake us off like a
bunch of fleas uh she's gonna get rid of
us but it's not going to be a gentle
shaking it's in in in the question is
how many
other uh beneficial uh organisms is she
gonna shake off with us it's it is the
trees the fish the animals are going to
survive
I think it's going to be a very good
uh half century for jellyfish
jellyfish I think are they're going to
be the winners so what's going to what
is probably going over the next 10
million years and and this this is the
sixth mass extinction we are in the
middle of all this crap when we are in
the middle of these six mass extinction
it began 10 000 years ago with the
invention of agriculture as far as I'm
concerned jellyfish I have so if I have
hope for anybody is jellyfish and that
is going to be the pool now I I think
plants have a little bit better chance
than animals
uh so hopefully there's going to be some
irradiated cockroaches that come out the
other side but it's going to take when
you look through the record it's
probably going to take 10 million years
for uh for this planet to uh to recover
from us and uh
I I I I I just think it's sad and uh and
you know people ask me well if you're so
sure that we're [ __ ] and you wonder
why why do you keep talking about it
does you know and my answer to them is I
I don't want anyone listening to this
who's not a Doomer to think
I am recommending that you
come if you have not stuck your little
toe into the doomsphere I want you to
turn around right now and run as fast as
you can get the [ __ ] out of here right
now you want nothing to do with it
however if you just happen to be one of
the tiny few people on this planet who
understand
that we are living through the single
biggest event in the history of our
species and you just happen to think
this is an interesting story I invite
you to come down into the doomsphere and
and you know come over to my channel
collapse Chronicles or there's all sorts
of channels another excellent place
source is is a website called medium.com
medium.com and just put in collapse or
social you know all of the terms Doom
collapse whatever there and there's some
excellent people uh and the other thing
that I
the reason I do this is because I think
people
particularly who are first coming down
here they think that they're all alone
they think that that Bob Dylan lied oh
my God am I here all alone from you know
Ballad of a thin man uh but you're not
alone and what the doomless fear offers
what collapse Chronicles and all these
others what we offer people
who understand the level of horror and
are willing to face it we offer a safe
haven that you can come over here and
you can talk and and you're not you're
you're gonna be respected you're going
to be appreciated you see what I'm
saying because people it's a very
isolating thing when when people your
best friends and your family members
don't want to you don't want to hear it
you can't go to a party and talk about
this no no and I and anyone in Austin
Texas I am I am a major party animal but
I I and and this interview will probably
get out to some of my friends in Austin
they will be absolutely horrified no I
don't know I don't I I do not talk about
this [ __ ] I don't talk about it
and if you are a Doomer and you're and
especially if you're new to this do not
get out there and talk about this to
your quote Normie friends it's not going
to win you you you're not going to win
friends and influence people about by
talking about this but when you do so
that's why you need the support group
and there will be more and more doomers
however they do every year the the
number of doomers is going to grow the
number of Clueless morons is going to
shrink and so this is going you know
there's going to be
uh more
uh more support
it's kind of more support for the people
that realize yeah more and more people
are are going to be figuring this out
and the other thing the other reason I
do this
is
I've been doing this now for you have
four thousand I have over 12
000 videos and various iterations on
YouTube uh
I've been doing this for 14 years if
if anything I have ever said in my
entire life has convinced
one person to have one last child
okay and if anything I have ever said
has reduced the population of this
planet by one human being
I am valid I am validated uh and my life
has been a my life has been a success so
that's my only
well this is how I wrap up is there
anything else was this avoidable is
there anything mankind could have done
we should have read Cervantes uh and if
if we had read Cervantes in the year
1500 if we had read
I don't know who
well I I'm scared to use the name Paul
erlich but if we had read Paul Ehrlich
in 1970 uh no we went we went over the
cliff as far as I'm concerned we went
over the cliff in 1970 uh Paul Ehrlich
and the population bomb
tried that that was the last warning uh
if you're looking
if you're just starting down here I do
want to plug a couple of books overshoot
by William catton C8 he's dead now
c-a-t-t-o-n
if you read any book that describes
what's going on on this planet and this
information is good Lord over 20 years
old now William catton overshoot
and uh
end game it's volume one and two by a
fellow named Derek Jensen
so start with overshoot and end game
and that spells it out and after reading
those books
if you think there's some validity to
what they're saying and you are
interested in this story uh come you
know come join us
uh
uh but otherwise you know people like
like so what is your advice and what
what people I don't understand
is I try to start my videos when it's a
pretty day here's how I start and end
every one of my my videos hopefully it
is a beautiful day I say and I can say
it today here in Southern California
what I say is
it is a
spectacularly gorgeous and I mean over
the top beautiful day
today here in Paradise in the collapse
of global industrial civilization that's
how I start every video and how I finish
every video and this is 50 of my message
but people do not realize but 50 of my
message is first acknowledge when it is
a beautiful day
be you know doomers are some of the most
grateful people on the planet we
understand that every day particularly
every beautiful day is a gift
and I close every
all of my talks and I'm going to close
this one about you you're welcome to
keep me on and asking questions the way
I end every video
is get out there and enjoy it while you
still can and that is I think it's not
is that a hopeful message it's just it's
just my advice it once you understand
what we're
what's right here in front of our eyes
this you know the brick wall that's
right in front of us you need to
appreciate every single
beautiful day on this planet you you
know you need to recognize that it is a
spectacularly gorgeous day here in the
collapse of global industrial
civilization and you need to get out
there and enjoy it you need to ring
every drop of joy every drop of beauty
that you can because this [ __ ] show
could go down tomorrow and you don't
want to be sitting behind some uh you
don't want to be selling real estate or
whatever your corporate job was or you
know what I'm saying you need to decide
for yourself how you are going to
comport
your life from here to tell you die
other than don't breed and and
bright red letters don't breed outside
of that there's there's not a goddamn
thing you can do about it there's
nothing
there is not one single individual
consumer and lifestyle choice you can
make their technology ain't going to get
us out of this the United Nations sure
as [ __ ] ain't going to get us out of
this there is nothing
anybody can do we're going down enjoy
the ride what would Bill Hicks say
enjoy the ride uh and I don't really
know what else to add your shirt says it
all
sorry
deal with it
it's a tragedy sorry I I am sorry for my
part in it uh
I'm sorry deal with it and and figure
out how you want to spend the rest of
your life uh enjoying everything you can
on every beautiful day you can
uh I don't know what else what else to
add to that day if you've said it all so
Sam thank you very much for sharing your
your thoughts on
well thank you very much for having me
on if anybody wants to come over to
collapse Chronicles on YouTube and
you can hear this every day all right so
uh get out there and enjoy it while you
still can guys love you all right sir
thank you very much